[Music builds]
I'm Kelly Slater, I've been on
the world surf tour for
30 years now.
When do you think you'll retire?
I'm tired, you know?
So many contests, so much focus,
so much discipline…
It takes a toll on you.
Aloha from the North Shore.
Yeah, here we are.
Season 2.
I guess we weren't that bad.
[Laughs]
The energy level that I'm feeling
is off the charts.
- You definitely get the goosebumps.
- [Laughs]
This year we've got the cut.
After 5 events
we're cutting the field down
to 22 men and 10 women.
If you don't make the cut
that's a huge mark on your career.
The cut's not fair for a lot of people.
Gabriel, he's the man and
he's the guy to beat,
but this is my time.
Toledo! Unbelievable!
Gabriel's already had his world titles.
Time for me to get one.
I want to win more than anything.
This is pressure like we've never seen.
It can be intimidating.
The fear, people react to it different.
I'm dead last.
If I don't make it here,
it's done.
It's like, I'm off tour.
He's not coming here
to participate.
He's coming here to win.
Kelly Slater, again!
Tatiana is below the cut line.
She got an injury.
Her career is at stake.
It's time to put your head down
and make a run for it.
You wanna perform
on the big stage,
and this is the biggest
stage you can have.
This is sport history.
- Oh my goodness.
- Oh!!
That was amazing!
[Music continues]